it's upon us folks first off spoiler
warning for this episode the pilot
episode the first episode of the show
loki when i talk about episodes of shows
i like getting spoilery
it's just kind of my thing so you've
been warned so the newest series among
mcu tv otherwise known as phase four
which is fine i'm actually really
enjoying that so
that's cool especially now the show is
loki whether his villain loki anti-hero
loki loki
established himself early on as a
memorable villain in the mcu and now he
has his own show because you know when
you're
low-key of asgard why would you not we
all knew it was set up from avengers end
game when loki got the tesseract he was
like peace
and it is it shows that at the beginning
of here as we pretty much figured it
would then the tva which is pretty much
the adjustment bureau for the mcu
timeline they show up to like no no
you gotta come with us because that
can't be happening and owen wilson plays
agent mobius who's pretty much this
relatable everyday guy beat agent you
know he's like a beat cop
for the timeline adjustment bureau he's
like let me talk to loki so it's him
trying to get through and connect with
loki that's a speed run
of the plot but that's pretty much the
gist of the episode
that the tva is such a boss [ __ ]
place that they use
infinity stones as paperweights which
per the explanation in avengers end game
means that
drawer full of stones means there's a
lot of realities out there that just
got screwed but if they're here i i
guess it means it was supposed to happen
so
eat [ __ ] reality sorry sometimes fate is
not a kind mistress you get the gist of
what this organization is
something that totally reminded me of
the mr dna
animation in jurassic park this cute
animated breakdown that's
easily digestible from all ages five
year olds
95 year olds everyone's like oh cool
i get it something about those animated
breakdowns they work but i love the
premise of this show because we're
dealing with a loki who hasn't
experienced anything we've seen loki
experience
past the first avengers movie he hasn't
experienced the death of his mother he
hasn't experienced
thanos snapping his neck you know this
is all of that hasn't happened to him
yet
he's seen it on a tv of his life he's
still got that loki
ego and i like the fact that owen
wilson's character is just poking and
prodding him he's quizzing him to
knowing the [ __ ] out of loki
but he's trying to connect with someone
we know is there
owen wilson's character thinks he's
there and loki's really trying to hide
it
but that connection does happen you can
tell when loki plays the events of his
life that he hasn't seen yet he's
hurting at the fact that he sees his mom
die absolutely it's
not even hidden but you can tell he's
touched with the fact that he sees
him and thor standing shoulder to
shoulder and we were all waiting for it
we're like dude the tape of your life is
right there so when's he going to
actually
push play and see thanos snap his neck
if there's a tape of my life right there
no you should not watch that you should
not watch your death it would sour the
experience of life
but i still probably do it i mean how
could you not i don't know how you
wouldn't so he sees it
it hits him something that someone told
him earlier in the episode something
that owen wilson tells him
he's not the star of his story he exists
as owen wilson said he's like you exist
to cause
pain and suffering so others the
avengers
can become better which is a rough
lesson to learn it's tough learning that
you're a support character
in the movie of your life at the end
owen wilson was like hey we need your
help because
the variants i guess there's this
variant variants are
beings that go out of their timeline and
start causing trouble and owen wilson's
like we need your help loki because the
variant we're hunting the one who's
doing all this is you in which i was
like you mean loki's mephisto
i thought it like you know that scene in
the church and the little kid
and owen wilson's like who did this and
he points to this stained glass window
showing a picture of the devil and i was
like oh i guess people are going to get
their mephisto but then i did think like
all right the horns could be loki's
helmet though because you know that
makes sense but after that reveal
i was then met with the thought of wait
this is that episode of the outer limits
right that's what this is i mean not
totally but there's this episode of the
outer limit series from the 90s where
this guy i mean he has a [ __ ] life he's
having a really bad day of it and anyhow
he's going to kill himself at work
and then he gets snatched through this
timeline and there's this other hymn
who's created this machine that can do
that
he's like hey i need your help uh
tracking down this
evil you this other you who's gone on a
murder spree
loki is that episode of the utter limit
but what i loved most about this because
tom hiddleston is a great actor
and i've loved him as loki but we
haven't gotten
that connection with him you know he's
had moments in the mcu for sure but
we've never
gotten that connection we've never
gotten a
breakthrough with loki i mean loki for
all intents and purposes
he's on the couch man he's in a therapy
session it's very elaborate one dealing
with
multiverse and adjustment bureau cops
maintaining the multiverse this was that
breakthrough moment this was that moment
where loki comes to
grips comes to terms with himself like
the scene where he's like oh this place
is just an illusion done by the weak to
maintain power that was a projection and
he tells owen wilson he's like
everything i do
the pain i cause i don't like doing it i
do it because i have to because
it's an illusion brought on by the weak
to maintain
power that's a huge moment that and the
emotion he was showing when he was
seeing the timeline of his life that
hasn't happened yet but that does make
me wonder how's this gonna go down is
loki gonna learn
lessons and then go right back to where
he left off like he never left so the
loki we
see in the mcu movies after the avengers
he's experienced everything in the show
loki so he's kind of just fulfilling the
timeline
even when he sends the dark elf
down the path to kill his mother and it
makes that a bit more impactful like he
had to send the dark elf there to
fulfill the timeline but
he he knows what would happen like he
knew what was going to happen i mean the
tesseract has to go back right because
if it doesn't then
that timeline is screwed ancient one
said so but if the tesseract was just
gonna go back
where it left off then couldn't the
avengers have just waited for it a lot
of possibilities as to where this show
could go that's why i feel like this
is the most engaging pilot episode of
the mcu shows that they've done yet
juan division i ended up getting sucked
into it later on
but it wasn't the pilot episode that did
it falcon in the winter soldier i was
like yeah it's like watching an mcu show
so i enjoyed it but this has some next
level
intrigue with some timeline [ __ ] i
really enjoy that
also shows that between one division
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
the new spider-man which is heavily
rumored to have
spider verse in it and loki dealing with
the harbingers
of the timeline i'm pretty sure marvel
phase four
and phase four through six if the
infinity saga says anything about it
usually these whole storylines take
about three phases it might just be
about the multiverse and timelines and
possibly destroying
all of that existence among all of it
you know the little things
you know my big takeaway in this episode
my big like holy [ __ ] are you serious
loki was db cooper i don't know that's
just kind of awesome i did a report on
db cooper in 6th grade
now we have the answer i mean it's not
like it can be disproven the bifrost
snatching up db cooper sending all the
bills flying it's
that's as good a theory as anybody so
the first episode of loki have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you